Runk
hello
hello hello are we starting is
everything going nice scared great great
episode 94 it's Sunday January 28th
isn't that beautiful ah nice you're
doing it a little bit different okay
yeah okay it's beautiful isn't it wow a
robot a
robot oh it's so you know what's so
awesome before we even talk about the
things how much when I eat I got to
clear my throat all the time for an hour
afterwards yes dude what's going
on what is it Mo mucusy man come on the
show just started gross is that gross
yeah I mean no not really it's only a
little bit though it's not a lot it's
just like it gets my fluids going I mean
now we're talking gross stuff now we're
talking Gross City look uh you guys this
podcast is not possible unless people uh
sign up for the lifeline luxury a lot of
you guys are on Lifeline luxury and we
appreciate you guys so much thank you so
much we love you and you want to uh join
Lifeline luxury you can it's patreon.com
Lifeline luxury it's just really really
now tell me if I'm wrong it's just
really really popping off over there
it's popping off yeah we do episodes
where there's no submissions where it's
just my brother and I messing around and
we have a good time we have actually
it's we have we really laugh hard but
whatever anyway uh also Matt's new
podcast best private record is out now
so go check it out on YouTube or
wherever you get your podcast check it
out and stuff yeah um and and then I'm
going to be on tour I'm gonna be on uh
in um what do you call it uh
Vancouver and uh can you pull it up H
100% And that's 100% obvious uh
Vancouver Colona um that chick dude
that's hilarious it was a Vancouver kala
um uh uh Rochester kitner
sheveport Louisiana Houston Corpus
Christie Durham and North Folk Virginia
learning how to speak learning how to
speak the way you said nor beautiful
that's a beautiful thing uh so yeah so
now obviously click out of it right so
what we would do is would be click out
of it and then we go back to the other
thing right there we go isn't that
interesting I don't want to have to talk
to people like a school teacher you got
a question you want to be on this show
go to watch lifefine decom you need some
advice you go to watch lifeline.com and
you ask for advice and we give it to you
unless you're boring uh you want one one
one one one one advice sessions with me
mata.com you do it you go there you get
advice your life's better and
everything's great and World Peace
happens after that uh you want the merch
go to life on
merch.com yay yay kind of gave me the
short end of the stick but as he
mentioned my podcast private record is
out in its own and popping and and
popping so I wanted to do that I wanted
to do DJ Quick hold on but what do you
mean I gave you the short end of the
stick you didn't I just wanted to do it
so I had to come up with a way to say it
again and I said you give me the short
end of the stick you said I gave you the
short end of the stick
Gunna absolutely terrorize me no I don't
understand why you said that can you
please explain it it's okay well I
didn't really get to expand on it
because you ran into your tour
dates but but I gave I did it up front
for you which is a nice thing I was nice
and I just wanted to say a little bit
more I I said it slow and nice thank you
I really did I I don't yeah I did I
didn't I wasn't like oh damn he gave me
sh in the stick but you did in actuality
because we're making jokes and what we
do is make jokes right well but they
need to have a little bit of Truth in it
right you don't just say not really not
when they're like that when they have
truth in them and they're like actually
like real that's not good okay right I
cuz it's like I I think when someone's
like why would you say I look fat in
this and they're like well I'm kidding
and it's like well cuz I only said it
because there's a little bit of Truth in
it and then you got a problem no that's
not true you know if I say you look fatn
just obviously silly but you said I gave
you the short end of the stick wow okay
but what I want to know is why you said
that cuz I just wanted to say bring it
up again in a real short way and that's
the thing that I chose to say I was
unexamined just wanted to get it done
but look at us now I'm just curious
would you just look at us so get the
long end of the stick yeah now it's the
longest possible the longest end I don't
know there was a short end we didn't get
it is there even such a thing as a long
end if it's a long end of a stick it's
just a big stick mhm a giant a giant
when you drink it magic mind that's how
I always sore my magic mind bottle cool
man it's cool
um you want to talk about magic mine no
we don't have to but uh also um what
were you saying about the long end of
the stick wow why cuz that was just not
great it wasn't great to see you know
I'm I'm I'm more organic wow I'm more
just kind of whatever whatever happens
happen do something so dick like that
ruin the aesthetic of the show and say
I'm just more organic so wait so uh yeah
dude um my son will go like that we were
talking about that earlier earlier on
ear before the show he'll be like Hey
Dad are you ready first of all he always
says are you ready watch watch this and
then I'll say what and he'll go like
this and like he'll look around and do
something you should turn it around and
with a real stern look in your eyes and
with a real Stern voice say are you
ready cuz he's not even ready so turn
the tables on him make him understand
that life is not uh uh walk in the park
this not some kind of cake walk well
Calvin like are you ready well Calvin um
are you ready I don't know if you yes in
your mind right now understand what it
is you want to show me so what is it you
want to show me say real quick right
yeah get them get them get catch him
catch him in the ACT uhuh we're both
wearing kind of like sweatshirts that
are like nice Down syndrome come on yeah
but you have Down syndrome for saying
that you can't I don't like that why
I don't know no it's you know what it's
all right people Rule and they bring up
cool stuff yeah you're right you're
right you're right okay take it back hey
take it hey so you're trying to you were
you were a little bit acting a little
bit too like I just you're virtual sign
virtual no I'm I I'm taking it back so
there's no signal but no for real look
at us look at our we have sweatshirts on
but I'm saying they're like nice ones
well where's that from well where's that
from rubber Outfitters so competitive no
I mean oh dogging me dude dogging me
dude no it's from Le TI what is it lean
well I don't know what that is me
neither it's just the brand it's a nice
it's a nice brand it's from the cotton
from Portugal or whatever and making it
up how do you know it's nice because I I
this I get a lot of their stuff got it
okay and it's the only kind of like
designer thing that I like yeah really
yeah it's you always care about labels
don't you want I do I've heard of Len
before I'm like don't you want to don't
you want to it Len yeah okay it's nice
yeah I see website so look at that guy
chilling dude he's chilling um it's very
like very comfortable clothing in fact
people that don't know what's up I'll
wear it and they'll be like oh well you
didn't have to dress up for this oh that
and I and I grab him by the collar I
pull him close and I said if you only
knew how much this cost me I don't like
if you only knew I don't like I don't
when people do that kind of stuff you
didn't have to get dress somebody said
that to me the other day and I I
actually thought I had something nice on
you probably did and they said that and
I was so confused and if it was you we
would have a half hour conversation
about why you said that yeah I wanted to
ask him so badly I didn't understand
what it was who was it that's so not
like you to not ask how nice all the
clothing is I think I just wanted to get
out of the situation I also just copped
a lot of stuff from there cuz they had a
sale okay so you're going to be seeing
qu you're going to be seeing quite a bit
okay of these things that's fine it is
kind of weird to be uh wearing
sweatpants during the day the whole time
but I do that it's a whole suit baby I
do that and I have the hoodie version of
this okay if you were a if you were a
chick would you be on only
fans and I don't even mean would you
show everything I have a really really
quick and readymade answer for you but I
wanted before I even answered I wanted
you to know yeah the rarely is there
such a definitive answer yeah the answer
is no no the answer is 100% yes oh
100% absolutely yes yeah cuz you don't
even have to show anything you can you
show feet just collect so much money is
that crazy we actually talk about this
the other day but like it's not life for
a hot chick is so
easy it can be right if you're not so
[__] up in the head cuz sometimes I
don't I actually have to say I don't
know why every hot woman isn't
absolutely crazy because wait wait wait
because the world can you say that again
I'm sorry I I want to make sure I
understand to be a hot
woman could you imagine but but no say
the thing you said I want to I want to
understand make sure sure I understand
what you said I can't believe every hot
woman isn't absolutely insane you can't
believe they're not okay yeah okay yeah
got because of the way people treat them
I agree right yeah so it's like it's
like you don't expect you
meet uh Brad Pit you don't expect him to
be normal right well no but but for a
lot of reasons right right yeah but
that's the male version of it right but
even Brad Pit who wouldn't be successful
he still looks like that no I'm talking
about the fame stuff you are talking yes
I yes I'm talking about the fame stuff
okay yeah um like you don't
expect you know shy labuff to be normal
he's been famous since he was 14 you
know yeah he's completely crazy I mean
whatever so it's like when you see a
really beautiful woman who's already at
this point 35 you're like oh well she's
got to be insane right and you're saying
when they're not it's astounding is that
saying yeah okay yeah yeah because
because of what you presume their life
experience to have been right yeah yes
the the power that they hold that they
either realize they have or they don't
realize they have well it's also on the
way men treat beautiful women so skewed
yeah it's crazy so they're it's like you
got no chance if you it's both sides
yeah it's not yeah it's not just women
but isn't that what you're saying is why
they have that skewed sense cuz they're
treated so differently than most people
yeah yeah okay I'm just making sure yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so uh so but what
they don't what some don't understand
understand is how easy life can be for
you if you are that and they and they
and they and they and why and why oh wow
dude Cutting Room floor Brian Gumble you
know and why and why why oh dude why
remember because like if you're a hot
woman and you're
26 and you're somewhere you don't have
to do anything everyone else will do it
for you and then all also you can just
be a millionaire you well that's the
last thing you said is the thing that
you can be a Millionaire right dude if
you're beautiful and a woman and you're
not a
millionaire what's wrong with you dude
and you want to be a millionaire well
right right right and you want to be a
millionaire yeah then then if you yeah
exactly if you're like oh I wish I had
more money like there's there's a very
that's all I'm saying there's a couple
very clear paths for you to do such and
and you by the way you don't even have
to show your your naked body you have
you don't have to do that you that you
can simply just be can we talk about
feet though what is the feet then what
is the foot fish I don't know I don't
have it some of my friends have it they
do yeah one one friend I don't think I
know I'm sure I know people that have it
but nobody I know has ever said said it
to to me that I know like I don't I
don't have it at all feet and I guess
this is part of it but they like touch
the ground they get dirty I don't think
that is part of it it's not part of the
dominance thing no I don't think so oh
really I don't think so I think a feet f
a foot fetish is just a a
a body part that like yeah like me and
arms yeah interesting or me and [__]
oops stup all right you want to go into
a submission or what let's do it it's
like me and balls and& [__] oh [__] this
the [__] what's up Chris what's up Matt
Lee here G absolutely love you guys
you're hilarious always making me and my
girlfriend um laugh all the time always
watch on lifeline and if not Lifeline
we're on congratulations so thank you
guys you're amazing quick question for
you
so I work in a luxury Market I sell
Luxury Cars Land Rover and jaguar and I
work with this guy and he is absolutely
and most utterly not funny his joke
delivery is terrible but he always makes
the same joke that he doesn't like me
usually if somebody would make that joke
more than two to three times it starts
to feel personal sure so I'm not really
sure what I should do obviously if this
were to be in the street or something I
would tell him to do something about it
but because I'm at work and I have to
keep a professional approach and not
like a weird tension in the air um is
there something funny I could say to him
to just absolutely shut him up or you
know do you guys think I should get
serious with him but then again I don't
want to make it weird so uh I would just
love to know what you guys think U but
other than that keep doing what you're
doing love you guys thank you so much
thanks bro dude that guy's cool dude
yeah cool look at him he looks so cool
he's cool dude yeah and he's bet he's so
good at his job sometimes guys are cool
huh yeah well you look at a guy like
that though and you're like oh you get
why uh like it I always think it's so
interesting like that guy could be
successful probably in a lot of
different areas yeah I know that and
it's like you know who I always think
about that is our our friend Jeff we
have a friend Jeff got it yeah yeah I
know him right yeah for sure um yeah and
it's like and and some people are just
born to do like me I could not be
success I could be successful in some
things but very few yeah one comedy no
there are my mind is crazy
what else could
you you're so lucky that's a thing oh
you don't think that saying saying oh so
dumb you don't you don't think that I
think that about you I always thought
about you like if that didn't exist oh
you'd be a straight hobo oh riding the
rails you know oh the Dharma bumps
saying oh is honestly saying oh about
anything is so dumb sounding dude just
oh oh yeah dude I I don't know but
you're amaz you're like a savant that's
what I mean though like understand not
amazing at the one thing and then it's
like they're inept at other things
that's
you is it kind of that way yeah yeah
yeah um yeah no maybe but I know what
you're saying about guys who are like
you could be anything yeah yeah yeah
true no I'm not like that but anyway
because sales is across like generally
that's for sales sales right right and
that's so many different businesses
making a livings making
livings in livings color so um all right
so I don't think you should try to make
a joke about it cuz then you sound
passive aggressive and it'll get lost
and it'll get messy and it'll be weird
anyway dude I did the most passive
aggressive thing the other day oh my God
go
ahead bro and I think I'll I think I'll
I it this is the definition of passive
aggressive and I didn't realize it until
I got called out and guess what I'm
going to keep doing it cuz it's so dope
oh okay okay so there we go but what is
it but but that's why I wanted to start
the the the story I understand okay and
we then we'll get back to the guy yes I
understand okay yeah the GTA character
so um hey man want to buy a car yeah
that's it just slowly walking in a
circle half circle away from you yeah
come on man let me show you I think I
got the right thing for you hey watch
out he says right after
that connected to nothing you did
okay um so I we were in Arizona me and
uh and Kristen I think it was
uh I think it was just us in the car
yeah it was and I was like how do you
get there so we have a thing in our
relationship when I when whoever
drives the other person will look up the
directions on the phone and when I say
that I'm realizing in the middle of me
talking about it that's wrong and not
true okay it seemed like something
tripped you up okay now I get it uh
because she's always the one that looks
up the directions no matter what even if
she's driving and I always want to be
the one that is I'll I'll do it you
drive she says no I like to use my [__]
oh okay all right fine but she's always
the one that looks up the thing no
matter what cuz I always want to use the
car one she doesn't want this she's like
you're an old guy I want to use my phone
that's such an old guy thing who uses
their actual cars you know why I like to
do it you know why I like to do it
because I like I don't like apple play
and then I like to do hey hey Mercedes
go home yes direct tell your car telling
your car to leave
you oh no so anyway get out so anyway um
uh she's doing the thing we don't know
where we're going we got to go to the
desert ridge improv we got to go see uh
Brian Ken you know oh okay and um and
she we get to the first turn the first
right or left okay now I don't know
where I'm going
right she's doing that on the with
Pokemons oh okay no I sit at the stop
sign and I go and I go like
this
uhhuh I mean
okay she and she's not even realizing
what's going on at all I'm like I'm just
going to wait as long as
I and where's the Mad meter then I the
Mad meter yeah oh dude it's a good thing
we have a sunroof oh you're a pissed oh
dude okay you you don't think it's funny
at all that that's happening because it
happens too much oh okay okay didn't
know that nice to meet you okay yeah
welcome to the world so so uh
so she is doing it and I go she's not
looking at me but I want her to look at
me now because I want to get there I
don't want to be late but also I want to
really land this [__] passive
aggressive [__] so I smile dude I just
go okay that's scary but I know and then
finally she goes Jesus what I say I
don't know where to
go and what how do she laugh she goes
babe come on that's so passive
aggressive just tell me yeah she said
just say just say hey which way do I go
right I know she is okay yeah yeah yeah
okay and any point did you express anger
at her no okay good but does matter no
no then you did it right I'm no I did do
it right but doesn't matter because
she's going to be she's going to be
upset oh that's no good yeah okay sorry
Kristen how many in your head have you
done to a girlfriend of yours where you
go like okay you got to be as nice as
you possibly can God you got be Story of
My Life hi
sweetheart it might not be the best idea
to leave the door open because the dog
can run away and she
just you go oh well [__] man or why
dides you say it so shitty and you're
like I I actually in my head made it to
where okay Chris don't do the thing in
my experience it's actually not even the
the crying it's like oh okay I know I
did it wrong but still I mean you know
so hard on yourself so it's [__]
stupid so anyway that that guy you
should definitely just approach the
person and be real and and and be yeah
you're dressed like be real so be
but first be like look I don't want it
to be weird at all like be as
straightforward and real about that cuz
that's true you're like I don't want
this to be weird at all but like what's
up with like the joke you always make
about that like I I wonder what he does
I'm starting to feel like is something
is everything all right like that's not
that's not even making it weird if you
do that there's a way to be weird about
that but it's not intrinsically
necessarily weird okay so just like go
into the thing knowing it's not weird
present it upfront as like you want to
make sure it's not weird and it won't be
weird and just ask
him yeah I wonder what he says I he says
he make jokes about how he doesn't like
him that's yeah which here's the it
always come back to the same thing for
me man this guy's like I'm starting to
take it personally and here's why he's
taking it
personally the guy's not funny right be
funny if you want to try to be funny
actually you have to be I did but it's
it's what it's like I always it always
comes up if you don't want to be a dick
be funny instead but if you're not funny
you're always going to be a dick yep you
don't rectangle rectang square it's like
that thing it's yeah it's not just oh if
I make a joke then it's funny no you
have to be funny on top of that the
there the joke itself means nothing if
the vessel itself isn't able to make it
you're right I mean how many times have
you made a joke and it didn't land and
you're like uh a [__] bro I didn't I I
didn't mean that I was trying to be
funny right not mean never it always
works but still no yeah exactly I've
seenly do that I'm saying me it's never
happened to me ever in my life I was
saying yes because yes of course I've
seen you exhibit that behavior because
it always happens to you but that is a
thing that is not done by me but mostly
you no it's done you understand what it
is because you do it understand what
because brother and I have no idea what
it is to experience the only reason why
it doesn't happen with you sometimes
because you learn from me but
anyway dude we're honestly we're such
Brothers yeah yeah g absolutely throttle
me the minute the second after he says
we cut the episode are we good have a
broken I'm going to have a broken skull
all right broken skull for a number of
reasons okay uh
next hey what's up y'all um I'm a big
fan uh my name is Draven I'm coming from
San that's sick and uh I was watching
your latest episode and I saw the guy he
was talking about how he looks at
reviews before he watches a movie which
is hilarious because my ex would always
want to watch like the shittiest movies
and uh I would be like yeah we'll watch
it if it has more than 67% on Rotten
Tomatoes and people say what they will
about Rotten Tomatoes but I feel like I
find that typically typically uh there's
a few movies that have like 30% that I
love yeah uh but but typically I'm in
line with like rotten tomatoes which is
so probably you know telling of who I am
but whatever uh yeah who cares I was
curious about you know we have our
favorite actors some of my favorite
actors are among
like it's like uh has never seen a movie
realizing now see Kristoff Waltz oh wow
Jesse Eisenberg wow Ryan Gosling
everybody's got to love Ryan Gosling uh
I'm into keano Reeves now I'm loving his
stuff we don't the list but anyway
obviously Leonardo Dicaprio and and a
lot of these are Big names that I'll
probably get hate from all the hipsters
and [__] that's okay you're good man I
was curious who are some of y'all's
favorite actors of all time and what do
you think draws you to that uh I'll
watch anything Douglas that class of
actor you know Camp if you will what
what brings you to that actor and what
makes them your favorite you know yep uh
I know Chris has said in the past he's a
big keano fan big uh alucino fan who's
not yeah of course uh but Matt I'd be
interested to get your perspective on
this yeah let me know so I I I genu I do
I love K Reeves love Bruce Willis love
you know but I will genuinely genuinely
watch anything with Michael Douglas in
it anything anything there's no other
person there's no other actor like that
for me you know what's up with Michael
Douglas what he's he is a great actor
but he's also he just is a great movie
star and there's that's difference right
it's like Denzel kind of yeah well
Denzel that the crazy thing about Denzel
he's a True Unicorn he's cuz he's a
phenomenal actor he's like a the best
actor in history and movie so for me
that is my you're saying Michael Douglas
that's who it is for me I would watch
Denzel was you watch the MC Beth one he
did I did watch it wow you watch fences
I saw fences I literally will see and
I've seen all the equalizer movies too
now but the there are a couple others I
guess Book of Eli I saw Book of Eli
that's truly trash trash movie safe
house is is cool he when he he has a
that's the best death scene I've ever
seen that's what I said really yeah I
said the same exact thing yeah he I
thought he died the best yeah he really
died the best dying on screen acting is
in safe house and you said this yes dude
we must have talked about this it is
probably oh you know what we saw it
together maybe I don't know bro but I I
actually was like saw I actually was
like wow it looks like he died he just
is sitting there against the the the
wall and just goes he's kind of crumpled
up on it yeah yeah and there's a moment
where you're like he doesn't even really
do much but there's a moment where he
does it and you're like oh he died oh
you think oh Denzel Washington died he's
dead yeah yeah rip check on Denzel Rip
but yeah he's uh he's the one for me
there are other actors that I love
lesser known actors that I love there's
this dude named Shay wigam well he's
great yeah he's phenomenal yeah if you
don't know who he is he's he he's Ste
sh's brother on bordwalk Empire he's
probably what he's most known for but
he's in a ton of [__] uh Nicholas Cage
is that way he's in a ton of true trash
but that's the thing it's Michael
Douglas I will I will watch a romantic
comedy with Michael Douglas the American
president I would watch any yeah I would
turn absolutely something about Michael
Douglas I think he's he's a he's such a
quintessential man to me you know one of
the reason why I like Bruce Willis so is
his dad that's weird actually both
Father and Son actors are like very much
like T classic prototypical male yeah
specimen male specimen don't do that I
say male specimen I don't like that I
like to say male specimen who did that
who did that it's uh what's his name is
it uh the guys on In Living Color no um
uh ladies man oh my god wow love
love the best SNL movie spin-off
everybody everybody loves to p with me
for this but I think it's it's so fun
ladies men ladies men is so funny yeah
uh all right uh so yeah so what was his
question though oh who do we like yeah
Michael Douglas anybody else well yeah k
Nicholas C anybody didn't say yeah no um
no just I mean trying to think of
anybody young like a young actor that I
I mean Ryan I love Ryan go great but
yeah great he's 43 um knows everything
about Ryan Gosling
Jake Jake Gyllenhaal's great um but
people I'll see in anything there might
only be one in that's Washington yeah if
there was one it's Michael Douglas for
sure that's cool all right we did it
great
job mg is still alive huh hey Matt hey
Chris uh shout out to Lifeline luxury
love you guys hell yeah so I know that
we've talked about people who are
waiting in line and when they get up to
cash register they take forever to order
well I was just in line for the ATM and
that was the most infuriating thing when
someone went up to take their money out
and they just [__] around and then
it's like they didn't know how much they
wanted to take out when they got there
crazy you take out one amount know what
you want to take out when you get there
yeah of course so I just want to know if
I'm the only person that got super
[__] angry or maybe I just need to
chill out I just remember and real quick
I do have a oops button from Chris and I
was just wondering when we're going to
get the Bing Bong button from M that
would I would buy that button so fast
love you guys dude what what how have I
never even thought of that Bing what do
you think of that when I go Bing I don't
the amount that's good what's the amount
that you take out so wanted me to stop
talking about the Bing Bong button but
okay what's the amount that you were uh
that I take out you said there's one
amount well no no he's saying know the
amount no but I was I I actually
misspoke because there is one amount
that I do and I don't think that's right
for everyone no yeah right no because
here's why I do one amount always and I
take out uh 300 bucks always but but I
probably do it
once you don't ever get cash never I
like having like a little bit of cash on
me I but I do I like because I get paid
in cash sometimes I don't that's why you
see me with the briss in hand okay I
don't like I for whatever this is so old
school to me this is so like Dad of me
but I don't really like depositing
bigger checks on mobile I like going to
the ATM to do it okay call me crazy I
just do you don't go into the bank well
I don't like to go to a teller ever dude
really yeah oh I love doing that okay
anyway I went I went to the ATM to
deposit some checks I go in the bank
they have the teller like the automated
tellers yeah it's not really an ATM
machine but it is okay anyway so I'm
waiting on there's this one guy one guy
at the machine and there's that's it
there's actually nobody else even in the
bank okay so I'm behind him I'm like
obviously I'm not one of those people
that's going to crowd I like I'm like
six feet behind this guy you stay far
back enough I'm as far back as I can
actually get because there's that island
where you fill there's the checking
deposit slip the savings slip I'm all
the way back against that the whole time
this guy's at the thing it's taken too
long okay taking way too long the whole
time he's looking back at me like this
oh
God and I'm and I realized like oh is he
paranoid so I then I'm like okay I'm GNA
like move my eyes so he doesn't even
think I'm do right right right right the
guy thinks he's invisible and then he's
taking too long and I'm like trying to
really bite my tongue like this I can't
do that anymore anyway he finally
finishes
up he looks back at me and he says
the line's over there I Look to where
he's pointing to where the line is and
no one's in it so he just wants you to
stand where you're supposed to stand
yes and I it took me to a little bit too
long to process what he even meant right
right cuz usually you like to do the
slamh right on the spot right and then
if you miss if you miss your slamh
moment it's gone you're like me though
it took too long you're like me though
you want to make sure you're not being a
dick for no reason and I was like wait
so sometimes it takes a little bit and
it took me a while I was like I was like
what what does he even think was H and
and and by the time he like got to the
door it was slamh opportunity was
already gone yeah hey by by the way yeah
exactly you can't do that the line was
where I wanted there was nobody in the
bank
so it's just like why are why are people
this way I people out there who are that
way why are you this way I I always
wondered everyone wants to know I always
wondered when I was going to start
really confronting people and I it it
because you see old guys and they're
like move oh yeah yeah when am I going
to be like that because tell you what
I'm gonna be like that oh it hasn't
happened yet I'm like that already yeah
it did yeah and I I and there's been
hints of it with me where I go hey what
are you doing this that it officially
happened the other day Okay I was in
line at the valet for my own
show I I wasn't going to give the card
valy I was going to park in my spot but
the valley was in the way right oh okay
and I was like uh the guy was taking too
long first of all the guy was taking to
long to get out of the car okay the
ballet guy no the guy the guy who had
the car oh okay and so I was like what
the [__] is going on and then so I roll
down the window and I say hey um what's
going on is it you know is everything
good or you know and they're like yeah
we got it and then I hear the valet guys
say to the guy like yo we got a lineb
and up like you God people like
it's taking entirely too long the guy
gets out walks around the the other side
of the car I can't see him okay the
valet guy is now at the passenger or at
the uh driver's side not in it but with
the door open talking to the dude
through the car on the other side right
okay the guy parked and and I'm like
well this is we'll wrap up in two
seconds so I don't have to say anything
sure yeah again now even that takes
entirely too long can you hear anything
no no no no I can't hear anything so I'm
like I already said one
thing I heard myself say hey move the
car it just popped out like I didn't
realize I said it he's like breathing it
just happened I couldn't I could I said
hey move the car huh wow and the guy
turned to me and he
said hey man I why don't you relax the
valet guy oh the valet guy yeah he got
in the mix jeez and I'm like well we got
to move the car man yeah yeah like
what's going on and he like I can't man
I can't right now and I was
like okay you know cuz also that I'm me
you know so I don't want it to be like
sure oh Chris Le is yelling at a [__]
ballet guy right
so so I get out of the car I park and
I'm like I got to say something to the
guy which guy I can't just let that go
like that the valet guy yeah because
what was happening see that's the
difference between you and me I don't
care yeah no I I got it I just want to
get what I get no I I got to know you
know why I got to know because what if
something actually was going on I need
to be like oh [__] my bad genuinely okay
we can assume something was probably
going on though right anyway go ahead
yeah yeah we can assume something was
going on but what though see that's what
that's what I'm saying I don't care I
couldn't get my big red out of the
center console big red lose my mind
right okay so what you asked him so I
walk up and I say buddy you could have
moved the car like what the [__] and he
was like yeah man I actually couldn't
and I was like huh wow and he says
because somebody stole a car the guy had
the car stolen and uh he needed to show
me how to use the key because it wasn't
working because how the car was stolen
and they Ed the key and I'm just like
okay well obviously there was just some
reason so now I know what's going on and
now I know what should have happened
what should have happened was the valet
guy should have said hey there there's
actually something wrong with the car
sorry but he jumped to to you yeah and
then he was like chill bro chill bro
well he was probably already FR already
aware he was holding everything up yeah
so so then I do the show oh wow okay and
I'm like you know
what [__] it it's not worth it it's
stupid I feel bad uhhuh I walk out and I
say to the guy you know in my head I've
got this romantic version of hey dude
sorry I got mad and he's be like dude
that's all right the car was like this
I'm sorry too you know y y cuz in my
head he's still kind of in the wrong of
course okay he is yeah um I come out and
I say hey man I say sorry I got so mad
he was like that's fine I'm not
tripping wait that bothered you that's
not acceptable why why why is that bad
that seems okay
say more like what I'm
sorry yeah and also don't say it's all
right I'm not tripping but what that
means is it's water under the bridge
it's I know but also say like yeah I
shouldn't have snapped so you want okay
yeah yeah yeah anyway did you say that
the OB actually you should come on but
now we see this you know yeah I should I
should I I should say the guy actually
seemed like a a good dude like the guy
yeah he just seemed like he was like
[__] annoyed you know yeah yeah yeah
but I don't know man it's weird people
don't say don't do that you know people
don't say sorry and a woman people don't
do wow you know s deeper people don't do
ever people don't ever do what you want
them to do
so put that in your pipe and smoke all
right I don't want you say that next one
how about that next
one yo what is up Chris and Matt big fan
of the podcast chrisk you been listening
since day one of congratulations that's
cool all right guys so here's my dilemma
I'm in a new apartment where my
downstairs neighbor is piece of [__] um
I'm on my fourth complaint by him by not
even being that loud whatsoever so I'll
have my speaker on at 50% and next thing
I know got the apartment complex calling
me the Qui hours between 10:00 p.m. and
8:00 a.m. I'm being disruptive around
4:00 p.m. and 10: in the morning
so normal hours of living okay um how do
youall go about the situation do I Stomp
Like an elephant and say [__] you to my
neighbor or I don't know go put a no on
his door or I don't know how to handle
this you guys looking forward to answers
till next time have a feeling about this
already I've thought about this kinds of
things I us to live in apartment and
[__] but like I I I think that it's the
unfortunate thing unless it's super
egregious see I okay so what I want to
say is it's just part of living in an
apartment if somebody thinks it's too
loud you should turn it lower but then
I'm like
also if you're a neighbor and someone's
playing their music let them play their
[__] music get over it here's the
[__] up if it's too loud obviously
yeah but here's the [__] up thing I
used to live in The Loft and uh I lived
there for a really long time and people
would come and go in the other units on
my floor and a few years in at first
when I moved in the people in the
apartment next to mine would play music
really loud so much so that the top
level of the loft where I would sleep
the wall would Shake that's crazy it was
crazy but they lived there before me oh
so I was like still still and then and
then it they moved out in like five
months oh okay so I lived there for many
years then about three years later uh
another couple movies in they're
actually really nice they introduce
themselves to me whatever but I notice
that at certain hours of the night
assuming it's when they like are
watching a movie together there's just
this Subway it's like there's a subwo in
my head it's it's shaking the wall it's
rattling the bed it's just like what
fart how loud are they wow you know so
IM mature how loud are they playing this
and at and then at a certain point I was
like I can't not like such a like loser
if I don't go talk to them yeah yeah
yeah I start feeling like that too yeah
you got to say something just also I
don't want to let let Let Him Live Let
Him Live let him live but then it's like
well let me live too right because also
you'd want somebody to say it to you I I
think I would right so I go over there
and I complain and he's nice about it
he's like what do you mean you complain
well I'm just like hey I don't know but
like it's really I tell him I just tell
him what's going on he's like oh okay
cool yeah wow okay and I realized he
doesn't think he was playing it
loud impression and I'm like but
whatever okay thanks he turns it down
okay next night maybe the one next night
after that same exact thing W I go over
there again I'm like hey dude I don't
know since we're like trying to figure
this out like and he's like he's like
you me to tell me your wall is shaking
yeah and I was like yeah and he's
clearly not like believing me I don't
know if I would either and I'm like I
don't really give a [__] if he believes
me and he's like he's like all right
well why don't you come in like I'm
going to show you we get in he puts he
hits playing the movie It's the most
tame really volume ever dude what my
point is sometimes it's just the way
shit's built dude the neighbor thinks
you're being loud not because you are so
don't think that like the Neighbors
being an [__] something about the
building might be amplifying it beneath
you so what did you so what did you do
then I was like dude I don't know what
to do we decided we realized it was just
the placement of the speaker was on the
ground in a certain Corner making the
wall like it was like where the speaker
was not at all the volume yeah did you
ever have him come over to your place
and hear the wall shake and then [__]
him well we [__] but he didn't come
check the wall Weck his place we made
the wall Shake but not uh with the
subwoofer yeah check it out check it out
my wall come in yeah it's definitely
shaking is that
crazy so
stupid watch yeah so my point is maybe
the person's not a terrible person it's
just like the way your buildings built I
had a neighbor like that that was below
me and below me that was below me and
she
was you know like 60
and I can't remember why but she invited
me to her apartment once to show me
something or something sound sexual it
wasn't but
um and she was like this is my peach
Palace into the like she was a [__]
like it was Super Mario Brothers and I
walked in and everything was peach color
yes
and no the fruit we ate it all peaches
everywhere and um everything was Peach
and she had like glamour shots of her
when she was younger oh wow it was crazy
wild what did you get scared for a
second like you thought n because she
was like really old not not just her age
but right right right I got it an old 60
yeah yeah okay all right no yeah all
right next one but yeah wait holdor yeah
we should say some advice what was it
which I think is you can write a note
back if you think someone's complaining
too much a note is is fine and cool and
just be don't be confrontational though
just be like hey if you would like to
come over and check out how not loud
this is I'm open to it but maybe we can
avoid the official Channel because I
don't think I play my music loud you
know be reasonable and then if they're
not reasonable back then you can
escalate because you have no choice
equalizer then you can
equalize but yeah try being reasonable
okay appeal to reason all right
hi guys love the show um Chris I have a
question for you
so uh I watched the golden hour and I
see your friendship with Brendan and
it's a lot like mine and my husband's
when it comes to saying I'm gay me
trying to explain something
and they're you know Brendan's like
getting it all wrong or just not
understanding and we're always like
that's not what I'm saying when I'm
saying is and I'm like I have those
conversations so much so I just want to
know like how do you make your point
across to someone who is not
understanding what you're saying and
you're explaining it over and over and
you're like am I crazy or you don't
humor humor have do it because I need to
learn you don't do it bye thanks people
won't understand you sucks you know what
I'm saying yep I mean we do
that yeah but I think it's fun to do
that that's that's that's the pro that's
the difference like I think it's fun to
to to try and explain something to
someone if they're not getting it I
think it's even more fun and so what so
she's like how do you she's say but no I
understand what she's asking but she's
saying and or rather implying that it
obviously is a problem for her and her
husband right have fun with it have fun
with it is that's what I do yeah yeah
yeah that's it and that's it and I've
thought about this a lot and that's it
it's also just to expand on that like
the way sometimes when you're like have
fun with it and someone's like but it's
you kind of have to explain how you can
do that and one way to do that is like
of all people in the world I would
assume your husband is the one you're
most interested in he has a mind that is
incapable of understanding things the
way your mind does that is interesting
try to get at or get into get inside the
way his mind works and have fun with
that is what I think he's saying yeah
okay cool all right or have fun with
divorce you know yeah or or get a
divorce see how fun that is a children's
book all right next
one hey guys quick video so much coke um
my wife does something that annoys the
living hell out of me and I can't [__]
talk her for it because she's my wife I
want to love her well sure sure okay but
the problem is anytime that I that's
annoying like have a matter of fact like
oh I didn't know that she will claim
that she does know that for example I
will look at a playground be like I
didn't know they had a really long slide
there and she like you didn't know that
oh and she does it on everything and the
thing that makes me the most mad is half
the time I know she doesn't know that
that specific park has a slide well
that's what makes it the worst
everything how how do you know that what
is a spin move that I can do to not be a
dick to my wife but also let her know
there in lies the rub right love you
guys Matt you're smarter Chris you're
funnier someone had to say if you when
you get when you get when you get
to
the I mean it's so going to get to the
point where he he just go he just like
snaps he just he say like no you don't
you know which is what he wants toid
yeah uh you came to the right place you
really did bro I couldn't not yeah you
didn't know that did you I I would do
that I I have done that I mean I I will
bring it up a day later if it like I
would I would bring it up again there's
no way could let that go [__] I'm
annoying but I think maybe
maybe
like or maybe even act like you think
it's funny and be like wait wait wait
wait wait but you didn't know that right
like like that right or something like
you you can't here's the thing you can't
keep letting it slide and do nothing cuz
like he was saying like my brother was
saying you will snap nah you know what
you do you will snap if you don't
release that valve I know what you do
okay go ahead when did you learn
that when did you learn
that you're playing with fire though
yeah I know okay but why why am I
playing with fire you're playing with
fire because what
that does yeah no y okay so I got a brle
for that because I thought that what we
going to say okay when did you learn
that so close to me when you put your
when did you learn
that why why did you want to know when I
learned that cuz you think I'm lying no
I want to know if I was with you or not
and wasn't paying attention because I
need to work on that and because you're
he what he was saying the way it goes
down was she says you didn't know that
you could also say because I want to
know why I didn't know that yeah there
you go bring it back on you yeah dude
yeah if you make it about you it's
always okay if you make it about her
you're going to get a divorce she's
going to divorce you yeah be careful
yeah cuz that's for me that is maddening
and I would just get in a fight about it
I guess yes I can relate to that not
that exactly that exact kind of thing
doesn't bother me but if I'll say
something about like some fact of the
world that I don't think the person I'm
talking to know knows and they're like
but you didn't know that I'm like no
[__] neither neither did you
well I would do that yeah now I know it
and you don't so why you acting like
it's the other way around right right
right right right right right right
right right this is not opposite day no
you can't fool me we don't Gaslight here
it's it's always the same day or
whatever the opposite of at the
end yeah that was a good one good great
great uh great great great question
that's that that actually gets me to my
core that's maddening though yeah you're
upset by that what
like why would you pretend you know
something if you don't know something I
mean I know why I don't you know what's
really hear me out I and I'm not I'm not
playing Devil's Advocate I really
believe this I think sometimes people do
that and they don't realize they've done
it until they said it already yeah I
agree and then so what so what I guess
further advice would be that might be
what's going on did you realize you said
that so be careful because you might
again you're playing with fire you might
be treading into territory where even
she doesn't know what she said that
would be amazing if you said did you
realize what you just
said then did you mean
it did you mean what you just said so
yeah it could be just literally a way
sometimes people communicate in ways
they use for phrases and yeah sometimes
you just say that just doesn't even it's
not even what they mean it's hard to
communicate with people so like yeah
keep that in mind as
well all right
next hey what's up Matt and Chris big
fan of the show um just I'm gonna try to
make it quick for you guys I moved uh to
Nashville about three months ago with my
girlfriend and it turned out that my
buddy from college was moving to town at
around the same time oh no so we were
really excited about
that I play music down in Nashville um
every
weekend and I was playing a gig one
night and my girlfriend and my buddy
they both came out to see me play I have
to play for four hours straight so I
can't really hang out yeah so you know
after they watched me play for a bit
they went and bar hopped and the next
day my girlfriend brings up to me that
my buddy had told her some stuff that I
had said to my buddy in
private uh basically my friend was
talking about how there's a lot of
pretty girls Nashville and I essentially
agreed with him but you know I followed
It Up by saying like you know I would
never do anything but you know I do see
them
this so he had like drunkenly like
talked to her about that I guess and so
obviously she's upset and she feels like
she her trust is being tested and you
know my initial reaction um I'm pissed
at my buddy like why would you [__]
say that um I don't really trust him
anymore and I yeah you know obviously I
got to be careful about what I say and
but this is just like causing damage
that didn't need to happen um wanted to
hear you guys' thoughts on it hope to
hear from you let me tell you have a
great day let me tell you something let
me tell you something this is this is
really I'm with Kristen's friend and
Kristen says something and Kristen's
friend says hey uh Kristen said there's
a lot of hot guys at uh where we live
and how she would never do anything but
also like she's [__] like wow man
sometimes it puts her to the test mhm I
I I swear to God I look at that friend
and I
say [__] you yeah right totally yeah
yeah why are you causing a problem yeah
what the [__] are you doing couldn't
agree more Yep dude that's what your
woman should be doing but if she doesn't
which most people don't they go what the
heck well let's not it's not get it
[__] twisted friend is the [__]
100% it's not Twisted yeah okay yeah the
friend is just saying that
because oh dude guys are [__] up when
it comes to chicks like that man dumb
[__] I wonder if that he confronted him
yet is he asking what does he
do deal it kind of yeah I don't even
know if you asked I I got blind with
rage so I don't even know what the end
of of it was I think it was like what
would you do uh generally but because
yeah he didn't ask like a specific thing
about how do I do this make a song about
it you're in n dude yeah yeah but dude
can't believe my best friend that I
think hot girls in Nashville you're an
adult I mean I'm playing it for four
hours and you went bar hopping and you
told her you got so drunk and you told
her and she didn't say what the [__]
[__] you but it's not her fault let's
not get it twisted it's your
fault this [__] friend of yours from
college deserves to have no more friends
yeah so be start that Trend where you
help him have less friends friend be the
first one on his way to friendlessness
okay he deserves no friends why do you
people do that well you know why guys do
it generally I don't know if this is why
he did it but the guy's trying to get in
there that's so that's even more [__]
up it is more [__] up you have to
assume oh you're trying to get in there
oh nice you're trying to get in there
well friendless let's let's give him the
benefit of I'm trying to get in there
now got to be friendless let's give him
the benefit of doubt he thinks that it's
not that big of a deal that he said that
okay [__] stupid then he's stupid
yeah because why why even like risk that
that's not the right word but you know
what I mean like shut the [__] up talk
about something else yeah why do that
why Rock the Boat that's [__] up Sit
Down You're Rocking sit down sit down
Sit Down You're Rocking The Boat Sit
Down You're Rocking sit down Sit Down
You're Rocking The Boat Sit Down You're
Rocking The Boat it's from HS pen 4 wow
I knew that yeah and I did the uh
Harmony Part nice that's not the
okay Melody Harmony oh
great um yeah it goes sit down your rock
sit down sit down sit down your rock in
the boat sit down your rock in
the Mr Kel the boat Mr Kelsey sit down
your rock in the boat that's the har
Harmony Part you know what's weird about
that is I oh [__] he died of cancer okay
sad mom the the what I was just thinking
about HMS sp4 that production of it what
because of H yeah Halal fell his foot
fell in a bucket right cried laughing
cried laughing he fell because he
wouldn't he didn't get black you needed
to have black shoes but he was like but
they were like what if you don't have
the money to get black shoes sure they
like put black socks over it put black
socks over his white idea
fell cried laughing cuz it was the stage
is slippery it's a theater stage he's
wearing a sock yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah doubly bad yeah absolutely
funny would be funny if he fell anyway
but the reason why he fell added to it
cried couldn't help it laughed everyone
else was singing I was not doing
anything but laughing oh you were
laughing on stage oh I was crying
laughing on stage everyone else was like
oh and I
was like that crying dude it was so
funny Hal was nice huh Halal is nice
Halal is still my friend and he's
awesome I don't mean he died I didn't
know you still talk to him no he's the
best he's the best I remember him being
a sweetheart yeah oh he's the best he's
the best yeah Sit Down You're Rocking
sit down Sit Down You're Rocking The
Boat Sit Down You're Rocking The Boat
that my part so anyway um I think I
think we're done with you doing that
yeah I think yeah you're done doing that
you think so both pretty sure Melody and
Harmony yeah all of it yeah okay Melody
and Harmony two strippers all right uh
Mel welome to the stage Melody m to the
stage Harmony should we
do dude you know what the best stripper
song is for
real what is it that the one I was doing
but what uh wow I'm blanking on the
other song the 9 in Nails
closer
I want to [__] you like an animal so bad
the way you're doing it I want to wow
that hurts so bad yeah I want to feel
you from the
insane just oh a smoker
yeah uh that's a good really top five
for sure yeah that that that one plays
well not anymore maybe I who the hell
knows what they play now in stri it's
possible now I would walk into club and
be like what is any of the yeah what are
any of these songs unless it's like you
know they still have the classics but
but years and years and years ago uh I
remember I was at a strip club and they
played closer three different times in
like 30 minutes or something like get I
love this song but do a different one
mhm all the same customers it probably
sucks when you're a stripper and then
they come on and somebody uses the song
you're like great now I can't do the
[__] song you think it's like yeah
yeah but I got some [__] up my sleeve
for that if that were to happen I got
some songs that nobody would use that I
know are really sexy that I would
[__] swing around my [__] okay man
you know I'm just saying it was Thunder
Down Under not stripping obviously I
wouldn't be in a female strip club with
females I would be in a in a dude one
and I would be swinging my [__] [__]
around and I I know what songs I would
be using [__] swingers the songs no no
the name yeah whatever the the place
would be called [__] swingers but I
would pick probably what is does anyone
know besides chip andell's Thunder Down
Under any like famous or popular like
male stripper things cuz there's a bunch
of obviously strip clubs that have
famous names but what are the male ones
is that it Chi Andals Thunder down all I
know is chi Andale and Thunder Down
Under do you know Butler's in the buff
no is that really one Butler are they
old and fat like Butlers or actual like
buters in the buff are private dancers
that oh we got with two or three of them
go to female or male got parties and
like they dress as sexy Butlers and like
serve okay people at the party as like
sexy Butlers like they're being Butlers
but in basically
naked buts in the buff how funny is that
would you like an OD derve basically oh
oh that's why P this yeah basically like
that dude this is how this is the song I
would
pick there's dick swinging around you
know what I mean just like know like
this just that's terrible like that just
like this so uncomfortable the worst the
worst
dude just [__] straight up you know
how dope that would be oh they already
used the [__] song by Trent resar
this sucks dude and what the hell are we
going to do oh [__] that sucks dude oh
Del it's you oh great H you know give me
the
hit that come out Chain's going crazy
like Chain's going crazy okay yeah I
could see it oh you know what I'm saying
oh they already used a trenant res great
what the [__] oh we used it three times
great he used it too that sucks
Vengeance used it as well Vengeance a
[__] dude deia you're up well you know
what I want I got
it going to hurt your neck next week
going to be talking about how your neck
hurts like I don't know why my neck is
messed up going to play that clip just
straight up dick swinging around not
good no I but well terrible terrible
show but my own [__] though what else
you just said just that you can't do one
nobody knows about that one in 20
seconds I'm just
like can he do another thing nobody
knows about that one everyone knows
about that one in some Porto head songs
but you get Vengeance Vengeance already
took it what happened Vengeance took it
all right I'll go Vengeance you know
what I want hurting his
neck the lip like a lip just bouncing
everywhere like a propeller dude I go so
hard with the propeller that I notice
I'm backing up and I'm not even using my
feet you take
off you got bruises on your head women
are just like old Dolby
sound
wow dude look at the buters in the buff
oh dude the first guy in the upper left
oh my God the first guy left
ciny wow so many of them are ciny the
butt with the butt the butt is my
favorite one yeah that woman being held
is so scared they're going to drop her
wow they're all so ciny GE is yeah
they're they're like a thing it's like a
very well-known I actually had a guy
it'll be on an episode eventually a guy
call in he was a butler the buff you
mean for uh record yeah and he had this
story about this horrible night going
totally totally Haywire because of a new
guy he had to break in that was like
totally terrible and [__] everything
up do you think he so seductive by Tonyo
I think well yeah I think so yeah I
think he probably did
yeah Butler's in the buff dude they're
all like nice and [__] using like Steve
Winwood songs and then all of a sudden
the new guy comes
in
holding wine spilling it dude he said in
a blanket all over the place he said the
guy brought his own beer and hid it and
tried to drink it the whole
time
that's that's so funny dude the new guy
too you know just the guy was like what
the [__] are you doing he's like he's
like what dude what it's all you get the
tono song on and he brought Coke he kept
singing up in the bathroom do c yes dude
you have to tell me when that one comes
out I want to watch it yeah for sure
anyway watch private record on mats
thing uh it's his new podcast and it's
great first episode's out second
episode's out um and uh also you can
come see me in Vancouver you can you can
do that song dude you can come see me
in Colona BC um and uh I got a bunch of
ones coming up uh uh Houston Corpus
Christie
shreport uh norfol and um some other
spots just go to crystal.com
uh private record first episode is out
second episode is coming out uh this
week subscribe on YouTube socials at the
private record everywhere you may be on
social
media yes 101 session with me mata.com
101111 mata.com get advice and of course
we don't really plug the merch enough
but the merch is [__] sick it is fire
as they say we don't do it we don't do
it is plug it enough people do buy it
they of course people buy it of course
they do it's great lifeline merch.com
come maybe we're going to get the big
bung buzzer we don't know we should do
some new merch soon actually it'll be
cool yeah we should uh all right thank
you everybody I love you
all
hello
[Music]
helloo